[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh aaron mcmahon
uh covers the michigan wolverines for
the ann arbor news
and mlive.com and we got drama this week
at least it feels like that aaron
there's normally drama leading up to
ohio state in michigan
and i got so many questions here as of
right now
is michigan practicing they are yeah
they started limited workouts on monday
they're expected to do the same today um
but
the chances of the game happening still
i'd say 50 50 at this point
why is that uh a combination of things i
mean
michigan was a banged up team before
they hit the covet outbreak last week
uh and then they lo they're expected to
lose anywhere between 12 to 14 guys from
coronavirus
and it still remains unclear how many
guys have been um out because of
contract
contact tracing so michigan's a um their
depleted
roster at this point depleted team they
may not have their starting quarterback
kate mcnamara either saturday
uh so this there's just a lot of them
certainly around this program at this
point who would make the decision
to play or not to play michigan said
it's on their
doctors uh they've take they've taken a
pretty cautious approach this whole
thing uh from from the get-go
um you know they've been following big
ten protocols um
but it's unclear at this point too how
many how many positive players they've
had you know
we've got we got a department-wide
number on last week on friday
the michigan's football program hasn't
specifically said so we're still unsure
um but michigan has said they've left
the decision in the hands of their
doctors and medical personnel
any word from jim harbaugh in the last
24 hours
no he was expected to talk to us today
at noon that has since been canceled
here in the last 10 minutes
so that's that's not good news if you're
looking if you're anticipating a game on
saturday
because we thought maybe that michigan
getting back into into workouts on
monday with a step
toward them playing uh while they're
while they are going to continue
workouts today
uh they're still going to remain limited
and what my understanding is that that's
just helmets
and not pads separate fact from fiction
if you can
because there was a report over the
weekend and maybe harbaugh was looking
towards the nfl
and then um i i saw a report
uh that maybe michigan is looking at
extending jim harbaugh's contract here
where do we stand with the future of jim
harbaugh yeah
the contract extension is no surprise i
mean jim harbaugh
even before the season told us that
there were discussions between him and
michigan's athletic director warren
manuel
about an extension uh they were tabled
that he said because of
the coronavirus concerns and the
athletic department's finances
so that's not a huge surprise but it
certainly it's a different situation now
now that michigan's off to a two and
four start there's a lot of questions
swirling two and six star excuse me a
lot of questions
swirling about his you know his status
and whatnot um but it's
it's it's a it's an interesting
predicament here because i think
at the end of the day and i've said this
before michigan i don't think is
interested in firing jim harbaugh
uh you know there's too much respect
there he's had he's had he provided
stability to this michigan football
program
and i think they like that um but you
know in regards to success i know i
think most folks would agree that
michigan
hasn't hasn't gotten over the hump they
haven't reached the pinnacle of the big
ten they
haven't gotten the playoff and i think
that that irks some folks
so it does sound like michigan has
extended a contract
extension to hardball i would not be
surprised if it's for fewer years and
less money than he was making before
but i i don't think michigan is ready to
walk away from jim just yet
well michigan might not be willing but
what about that fan base what about the
boosters the alumni
it's yeah it's starting to grow there
there has been
some more you know criticism especially
the last few weeks given michigan start
to this season
um and and i wouldn't say that was the
case as much before the season started
um you still had a large faction of
folks that were happy with jim harbaugh
and the job he had done
because you got to remember i mean
michigan's program has by and large been
relatively clean they've been
you know the negative headlines have not
been there um stability has been there
they've won enough
games remember jim harbaugh you know
while he hasn't got michigan the big ten
championship he's won about 70
of his games he's coached uh so they win
more than they lose um
so yeah there is there was a growing
faction that liked him and still wanted
in there and i do
i still i still believe that michigan by
and large
uh is happy with the job he's done but
yeah the fan base and and the boosters
are starting to grow
you know frustrated i think at the lack
of a lack of results if i said to the
fan base
michigan plays ohio state or michigan
does not play ohio state
what do you think the fan base would
vote for
i'll go off based off my emails and what
i've seen i've gotten on social media
it seems like the majority of the fan
base does not want to play saturday's
game because of
the the fear of what could happen and
when i say that i mean
them getting blown out to epic
proportions and it's it's not out of the
you know
the realm of possibility in the last few
years michigan
who has arguably you know a better team
than they have this year
uh they they struggle uh and going in
there this this
this you know this year uh perhaps with
down their third string quarterback
uh i don't think the expectations are
for you know them to keep it close so
the fan base i don't think wants
saturday's going to happen uh they're
ready for the season theoretically to
end and then kind of and
but i think there's clarity desire there
too they want to know what's going to
happen with jim harbaugh
whether he stays or whether he goes um
and i think that's what's made this this
week so interesting
but also you could ruin ohio state
season in qualifying for the big ten
unless it feels like the big ten's going
to do whatever they can to crown
ohio state a big ten champ or you know
whatever it is so they can
you know qualify for the playoffs or
whatever is going to be
you know added to this but could you see
michigan
could could you see michigan opting to
do that
where we don't play them therefore we
can't get blown out and we could do some
damage to ohio state in the big ten race
i i think the first two things are valid
i don't know if there's an inkling
behind the scenes at least within the
program to
you know quote unquote destroy ohio
state season i i don't
for note from you know dealing with jim
harbaugh the last couple years the way
he operates i i don't think that's the
case i think
i think generally if you ask jim
harbaugh i think he'd want to play this
game
uh he'd prefer to um i know there's a
desire to practice you know uh
last late last week and even play last
weekend's game but michigan's medical
doctors thought it thought otherwise
uh so i i don't know it's hard to
address that just because
yes i think there's a segment of the fan
base that would like that just because
they haven't been able to beat them the
last couple years
um but i i think to say that you know
the folks inside the program necessarily
want to destroy ohio state season i
think it would be inaccurate
and like you said i think the big ten is
ready to step in and make sure that
you know ohio state does play a sixth
game or amends the rules entirely and
lets them into the big ten title game
next week
you know having only played five games
man it's crazy
it is it's crazy and i don't believe for
a second jim harbaugh
doesn't want to play this game uh he
might deep down
know that this could really you know
this could be really embarrassing but
i you know the competitor is i've known
harbaugh 30 years i just can't imagine
and his dad
i can't imagine that he would go you
know what let's take the easy way out
and not play that doesn't mean
they might not play this game due to
covid but i don't think for a second
that harbaugh would allow them
uh should be next uh interesting next
couple days there for you aaron we
appreciate your time thanks for joining
us
no problem thanks dan that's aaron
mcmahon a michigan football beat
writer for the ann arbor news and
mlive.com